Argyle is it's pretty crazy
mindblowing smart
sexy it's called reality but it's
Matthew Vaughn so it's a heightened
reality you can't always understand The
Madness of Matthew vaugh you just have
to go with
it it's an interesting mix of reality
and fantasy to reinvent everything you
think you know about spy movies the
greater the Spy the bigger the
LIE there's always a surprise there's
always lots of excitement it's wild
anything can happen trust
me definitely unexpected going to be
slightly mad watch this and it's
non-stop wherever you think this movie
is going I love this book you are wrong
it's time for you to meet the real agent
Argy oh my God oh my God oh my
God
[Music]
henty